yes i think it was a mistake it was a
mistake i apologize for
uh
for it i think in in hindsight it was
the wrong thing to do uh i apologize to
everybody who's been badly affected
by it and i just want to make absolutely
clear that there's no place in this
government for
anybody who uh is predatory or who
abuses their position of power did you
want to joke though pincher by name
pincher by nature well what i can tell
you is that uh
if i look at the background of this and
why i regret it so much is that uh
about three years ago uh there was a
complaint made against uh chris pincher
in the foreign office uh the complaint
was was uh
cleared up he apologized uh it was
raised with me
uh in uh orally there was a i was i was
briefed on what had
had happened and
you know if i had my time again
i would think back on it
and
uh recognize that uh he wasn't going to
learn uh any lesson he and he wasn't
going to
to change and that you didn't deny
that prime minister this is about truth
isn't it it's about whether people can
believe what you say and we now know
that those who speak for you over the
last few days have said things that
turned out to be untrue did you lie to
them no and let me let me explain what
uh what what happened so
uh this is the
uh we're talking about
a series of uh events over or series of
appointments over several years so
uh chris pincher came into government as
deputy chief whip uh before i became uh
prime minister uh he was moved to the to
the foreign office uh he then went on to
to be a minister for
uh for housing
and uh we then moved him back to be uh
to be deputy chief whip as i say about
two and a half years ago i got this
uh
complaint uh it was it was something
that uh was only raised with me very
cursory but i wish okay that we had uh i
in particular had acted on it and uh
that he had not uh continued income
because he then went on i'm afraid to
behave
as far as we can see according to the
allegations that we have very very badly
there we are that was the prime minister
admitting it was a mistake to appoint uh
chris pincher and he has apologized
skye's deputy political editor sam coats
is in west winster westminster so sam
what did you make of what he had to say
well first of all mark another apology
has there been a prime minister in
modern times to have apologized so many
times for so many different things in
just one year whether it was the owen
patterson affair whether it was parties
or now chris pincher those are all
things that have forced boris johnson in
front of the tv cameras to the dispatch
box in order to issue abject apologies
for his mistakes the second thing that
leaps out is an argument that boris
johnson makes in that uh interview that
we just heard essentially he's saying
i should have realized when i was first
alerted to the 2019 allegations that
somebody like that doesn't change their
behavior i should have let him go
entirely made sure he wasn't in the
position he was in uh last last week
when he uh uh
there was an assault in the uh carlton
club uh uh allegedly and uh i think that
argument from boris johnson that he
should have realized that people don't
change uh will be examined quite closely
by conservative mps who are also asking
the question whether or not boris
johnson who's had to apologize for so
many things will change himself then the
third thing that stands out a mile from
that short interview was that when
challenged over whether chris pincher
uh was
he described pincher uh as a picture by
name pinch by nature there was no denial
that he used that remark making
absolutely clear that he would have been
very aware of what was going on uh and
as a consequence using that kind of
language about chris pincher i think
now that the prime minister on camera
there not denying
it
will
prompt further questions among story mps